I can't [ __ ] is that your boy
psychobabble with playing grand theft be
I like you want to do the B is a
renewable 45 but it's actually nice it
is a fee after the producers daughter
Victoria
anyway we're doing the mission of the
Chinese come on you sure as [ __ ] are one
dumb ignorant white trash hillbilly
wallet yeah damn right the Chang
spreadsheet let's head outside and talk
terms no idea gentlemen I think I have
proved that my organization can handle
weight and I think I've proved that my
organization is a reliable supplier in
short it's you me now give me some of
that goddamn act I'm afraid we want to
go down a different path what we want to
explore other opportunity on white off
or twice Allah yeah we will [ __ ] me
uncle you buy me [ __ ] up our boss mr.
Chang's father wants something a little
larger we want to move drugs bats guns
this is my life's work I mean since I
was a little kid I dreamt big and I've
always wanted to be a international drug
dealer and then weapons trader all right
so I'm begging you let's make this
happen I'm very sorry you're sorry
you're [ __ ] sorry I just spilled my
[ __ ] guts out to you and you say to
me you're sorry who are you working with
hmm I'm not at liberty to say no no no
you're at [ __ ] Liberty in fact I'd
say you are obliged huh the old nail
process the O'Neill brothers huh yeah
you shouldn't me know cuz those [ __ ]
O'Neill brothers I hear a little birdie
telling me that they have a bit of a
problem since one of them's gonna have
to be surgically removed from the skull
of the other [ __ ] you guys and [ __ ] them
this is [ __ ] insane
ah music off [ __ ] wrong that's what
I'm looking for get get get it anyways
let's go [ __ ] up the money about it
I [ __ ] up the car not too bad
that's my aerodynamic now yeah
chef are we gonna have to go gonna end
up in the trunk of this thing Trevor
Phillips oh wow yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you Trevor its business
that wide-eyed idiot was mine it's
business Bella you want to discuss it
we're at the farm early Earl Walton
windale Doyle Darrell and all of us
start writing those names on tombstones
cuz I'm on the way to your lab and we're
gonna see how much of a family miss
business you got when I'm gone Jason I'm
inbred a minute haha why is that like
instructor
all right [ __ ] that's blood up there
there's a lot of what
to the caf
[Applause]
malian a family five
11
now
I got slow vantas I'm right here okay I
like
no way that's it sorry looking like I
just spoke to that maniac Trevor he's
coming get down to the meth lab to
protect it all right hope you don't get
through these idiots but we know they're
idiots come on let's go see them Chinese
villas tonight oh how many brothers you
got you inbred freak I don't know how
I'm gonna do it but I'll kill all audio
and I'll torque your cookout
good God shut the [ __ ] is left
music dude that's [ __ ] insane
I guess I'm just gone in
it's sorry please come out Plus trevor
phillips me the Martha
take over time
we got a man now you get out this
property look like a larger operation
yeah [ __ ] weirdo get going where's
O'Neill I hear get our house now [ __ ]
trailer
[Music]
are they
[Music]
hey is upstairs
[Music]
here I come you prick
where the [ __ ] is it
[Music]
okay well it's fairly in the basement
let me check again
[Music]
by the store
here we go found the cooks I don't come
on a culture all right you win
yes ms laughs oh you're gonna burn you
idiot come on come on craft back
[Music]
we
come on occasion hey
you disrespectful break
[ __ ] a
disguises
thank ya thank ya